vous avez vu hier soir un témoignage
presque insupportable de patrick henry
enregistré après un premier
interrogatoire avant qu'on ne découvre
le corps d'enfants de l'enfant dans sa
chambre d'hôtels meublés
mais cela ne suffisait pas pour que cela
soit considéré comme un véritable
portrait de cet homme inquiétant et bien
ce portrait tracé encore à grands traits
grâce aux témoignages de son entourage
et de ses médecins
le voici par jean-louis burgat éducation
normale famille normale activité normale
tout est normal ou presque dans la vie
de patrick henry
jusqu'au 30 janvier 76 et c'est bien ce
qui est terrible naissances au sein
d'une famille de six enfants le père
etienne est vendeur dans un magasin de
sport la mère madeleine travail dans une
blanchisserie normal mais tout de même
pas facile tous les jours avec cinq
frères et soeurs à 10 ans patrick entre
collège saint-pierre cours privés
catholiques fréquenté par la bourgeoisie
de 3 il contemple alors chaque jour des
enfants qui ont beaucoup plus d'argent
que lui et a 18 ans lorsqu'il sort du
service militaire il n'a qu'une seule
idée faire de l'argent et vite
il changea plusieurs reprises de travail
vit au dessus de ses moyens grosses
voitures club hippique costumes cher
dette crédit encore des dettes et trois
chèques sans provision tribunal prison à
la sortie le même manège reprend mais la
roue tourne encore plus vite là il ya un
accident de voiture un choc nerveux
plusieurs consultations chez un
psychiatre qui trouve un garçon
velléitaire une déprime de non réussite
c'était l'année dernière
patrick avait 22 ans à bosse en cours le
village où habitent ses parents au dit
alors que le playboy blond est
maintenant prête à tout pour du fric
voilà ce soir ce que nous le portrait
que nous pouvons faire à partir des
seuls éléments dont nous disposons et
bien entendu au cours de l'instruction
la personnalité de l'assassin se
précisera mais je conçois que ce ne soit
pas le plus important